you
you
welcome to the live stream of the 20/20
Donald Trump State of the Union address
we are in for quite a show today folks
quite a show we have live video at the
White House of Donald Trump's limousine
ready to at some point make its way the
very short distance over to the House
chamber on Capitol Hill we expect the
speech to start somewhere around 907
p.m. Eastern Time officially scheduled
for 9:00 p.m. there will be a pump there
will be circumstance there will be all
sorts of different things and what
incredible timing for this State of the
Union address we have Donald Trump's
impending as the door is now opened and
Donald Trump prepares to exit to his
limo we have the impending acquittal of
Donald Trump in a Senate impeachment
trial will that be a topic tonight we
have the Iowa caucus results after a
disastrous embarrassment by the Iowa
Democratic Party still we don't even
have 2/3 of the results ladies and
gentlemen I will update you on the
results that we do have it is going to
be an incredible evening and it to me is
one of the most what are we how do I
even describe it this is one of the most
it's not a consequential State of the
Union it's just one riddled in scandal
and controversy on an election year as
the Democratic primary is getting going
so it is going to truly be a very
interesting thing to see well Trump
talked about Iowa well Trump talked
about will he talk about a mini Mike
Bloomberg will he talk about all of
these different things I have no idea
these speeches typically run anywhere
from as little as seventy five minutes
to as many as you know hundred minutes
in duration and it is going to be very
interesting to see what does and does
not make it into the speech so up until
the time that they start welcome I will
take questions from you via super chat
if you are watching
on YouTube I already see super chats
coming in you're watching on twitch I
will take messages via twitch
subscriptions twitch Prime and other
subscriptions let's see what's on
people's minds we are once again running
the coupon code 36 today remember that
Sunday was my birthday we ran a discount
36 today saves 60% we are it is still
available and you can use it at join
pakman.com our goal is 50 members
yesterday during the caucus stream I
think we had like 80 so I hope that we
can do 50 it would be absolutely
fantastic as we see a shot here of the
US Capitol on the left the White House
on the right very quickly let's take a
look at the latest caucus results that
we have this is still with just 62
percent reporting pete Budaj edge lien
leading in state delegate equivalents
over Bernie Sanders ten and ten pledged
delegates and effective tie Elizabeth
Warren getting four as of right now zero
pledged delegates for everybody else and
we will talk about the implications of
these numbers tomorrow and of course
this could reverse still we could end up
seeing something very different develop
let me see if there's anything else I
wanted to look at here I guess not I
mean I guess for the yang and Tulsi
people andrew yang at least got a
delegate Tulsi Gabbard just zeros all
across only 232 votes at all so if you
are in the Tulsi crowd and still believe
that Tulsi is going to be the nominee I
certainly want to hear from you because
I simply don't see it I simply don't see
it all right let's get to Super chats as
they are starting to come in a first
Super chat is from hound dog there will
be big brain glitches and tweaking out
yes so please find let me see first of
all I just had this Trump Trump was
highly triggered by a fat pic ad that
Mike Bloomberg ran of him and he started
tweeting things about Mike Bloomberg it
actually is hilarious when Trump does
some of the stuff Trump tweeting I I
laughed out loud when I saw this mini
mic is now negotiating both to get on
the Democrat primary debate stage and to
have the right
not boxes or a lift during the debate
I like how do you negotiate standing on
a box it's like either they let you
stand on a box or they don't this is
sometimes done but not really fair I
love that but what I actually wanted to
point your attention to is play so do
2020 bingo with me okay we have if you
look at my there's the Tesla stock if
you look at my tweets from earlier today
we put together a special bingo card for
tonight's debate and which of these
things will Donald mention of course
free square in the middle will Trump
mention socialism will Trump claim to be
building the wall perfect phone call
impeachment hoax witch-hunt slurring his
speech is going to be a big one we're
looking for referencing crazy bernie or
mini mike talking about China which is
China that's how he says it sniffing
constantly toilets we know he's obsessed
with toilets and the flushing of toilets
read the transcript which he didn't
release pointing to someone in the crowd
and referring to them as my
african-american shifty shift the
do-nothing Democrat Party black
unemployment having the cleanest air and
water Greta referencing Greta tune Berg
Obama Hillary Pocahontas windmill cancer
exonerated and corruption okay so please
retweet my bingo card and follow along
because it is going to be a real party
folks it's gonna be a real party today
alright more Super chats coming in Dutch
morgen Dutch Morgan says I remember
watching your videos in high school
around 2015 it was very unpopular to be
liberal you'd be surprised how
conservative Chicago suburbs actually
are keep up the great work thank you
appreciate the longtime support TJ says
so rude to Tulsi by calling her Tulsi I
don't get it I'm not sure I understand
and pare tearin' checking in from Sweden
as he often does with the message hi
friends appreciate seeing you pear
always great to see pear in the chat if
you are just joining us the State of the
Union address expected to start near at
the top of the hour we will see Donald
Trump eventually make his way into his
limo over to Capitol Hill he will come
in
be announced by the sergeant-at-arms
there will be handshaking I am genuinely
curious whether this time around because
of the political environment because
this guy is under impeachment are the
same Democrats who are impeaching this
guy going to be wanting to shake his
hand and take pictures
I would actually respect them more if
they avoided the opportunity for that
and just ignored the guy I would
genuinely like to see that excuse me
welcome to crow rebar who has subscribed
with a youtube subscription kicking off
the join pakman.com memberships is
Cassie Cunningham Cassie your new member
number one of the evening we do have a
coupon code 36 today
saves you 60% because it was my 36th
birthday on Sunday we created this
coupon code 80 people used it during
yesterday's stream by all means feel
free to do it I will Thank You profusely
I will see you forever as a really great
person and it's available at join
pakman.com let me say thank you to rebel
without a cause for subscribing with
twitch Prime and Mystic Valley for
subscribing with twitch Prime William
Gilbert is asking will I be streaming
the whole speech and commenting love the
show hope you're doing well yes I will
unless people want me to end the stream
in which case I will do it aviator x-23
sends a super chat make it simple says I
guess some people think you're saying
Tulsi Tulsi cat alot says happy birthday
David witching wishing you much success
hopefully Bernie the candidate will be
another gift only time will tell
only time will tell if you are just
joining us we did briefly look at the
latest Iowa caucus results as you can
see here still with 62% of precincts
reporting Pete Budaj edge leading in
total state devil a state delegate
equivalents we will likely not have
final numbers until tomorrow as you can
see down here 62 percent reporting and
there are all sorts of conspiracy
theories about uh you know they picked
the 62% that are good for Trump I'm
sorry that are good for Budaj edge and
to get him another round of headlines
and so on and so forth
listen we don't attribute to malice what
we can easily attribute to incompetence
and there is a lot of incompetence to go
around in the Democratic Party so until
I have evidence otherwise that's where
I'm leaving it let's see if we have
audio coming in we do okay so we'll just
run the audio and hopefully the mix will
be okay so I can talk over it and people
don't go crazy see a lot of our friends
coming in senator Tim Scott just came in
I mean not my friends wouldn't be caught
dead with me but you know people we know
who else do we see here that might have
been Marco Rubio who walked by there's
Kamala Harris we see oh there's Rand
Paul walking by maybe Susan Collins
walked by at some point Andrew Scott
says via super chat the top boo dead
judge donor is the founder of the app
company isn't that ironic grant Blevins
Nancy Pelosi standing at attention Grant
Blevins says how great would it be to
see Trump stumble getting into the car
there could be a lot of weird stuff
going on but it looks like that's Mike
Pence entering the House chamber now
disappointing sight to see of course let
me say thank you and welcome to Johann
sis and Chris Russell who are new
members number two and three of the
evening starting to push the blue line
across the screen some of you who were
here yesterday know that we reached
eight hundred thousand YouTube
subscribers yesterday live on stream as
Donald Trump is getting into the beast
and will soon be making his way over to
the House chamber we will just turn down
a little bit more this background I
think is fine we see Melania Trump of
course very much against bullying is
Melania although her husband is one of
the greatest bullies around they are
going to make the
way over to the house chamber grant
Blevins already okay we read that one
Jason White sends a $2 super chat thanks
Jason yeah we I will there's Mitch
McConnell and Chuck Grassley we are
taking questions and comments via
YouTube super chat and twitch
subscription messages and I will keep
answering them until they get started
President Donald Trump's limousine very
slowly starting to leave the White House
and will make the very short ride over
to where we just saw Chuck Schumer we
see Mike Pence shaking hands with people
I've deliberately not looked into who
are Trump special guests or whatever
will it'll all just be new to me I am
curious how much the Iowa caucus will be
a topic of discussion curious how much
impeachment will be a topic of
discussion Scott Phillips says happy
belated birthday did you hit 800,000
subscribers we did we actually hit it
yesterday we are now almost we are
actually halfway to 801 so if you're
just joining us let's keep the party
going make sure you like and subscribe
liking the stream is really good for us
because YouTube gets tricked or
accurately believes that this is a good
stream to promote to people looking for
impeachment coverage so always make sure
to LIKE and then subscribe
dillinger sladac says am I the only one
slightly peeved when Trump claps his
hands so close to the mic and it's it's
s I kept saying sladac
OC Attucks IC yes when I super chat it
said I'm sorry that's Dillinger C attic
whoa what just happened just got a weird
we almost lot we just lost video there
briefly and we are back Nancy Pelosi
talking to Mike Pence and they seemed to
be having relatively friendly
conversation Adam the D no sorry I
skipped one skipped a few squirrel dude
says hot take the Dems rigging contest
against Bernie is what's happening
because I don't know they did it in 2016
good hot take you should have a show
Daunte ghee says cheers love the work
always clear and sane Adam the deed do
do should interrupt Odie's should
interrupt the speech one by one over the
hour but then the rules for the not-me
republicans would cry my decorum and the
democrats are simply not brave enough I
don't believe Democrats are going to do
that I don't believe they will a MOS a
moly O's or illios is a new Youtube
subscriber Ben Taylor says good to see
you David as always I can't believe you
can keep up with every with who everyone
is in their relevance to the situation
so much less work for me yeah I mean
listen that's Mike Pence and Nancy
Pelosi I hope that's the I hope that's
useful to you we do have a group of
members of Congress I dressed in white
they did this last year we see that
looks like Ilan Omar and other people I
don't recognize we see Rick Scott coming
in here senator from Florida who else do
we see coming in believe this is Lee
Zeldin - you're right Republican
congressman and a total bomb thrower we
have is this Cory Booker down here I
can't tell from facing away that's
definitely Nancy Pelosi though that's a
Nancy Pelosi for sure let me say thank
you to know nobody else to say thank you
I will remind you we are still today is
the last day of the birthday special it
was my birthday on Sunday I turned 36 we
have a coupon code 36 today that'll save
you 60% off of website memberships at
join pakman.com so far three people have
signed up I would love for that to be 30
rather than three the goal is 50 and
every time someone signs up the blue bar
moves over it inches along like an
inchworm and I say your name I thank you
and people just get very excited and
happy when that happens let's see here
Tyler Sylvester says Trump's mannerisms
sometimes remind me of the late Libyan
dictator Moammar Ghadafi I've not
noticed that but I'm not that familiar
with Gaddafi's mannerisms I admit
make it simple says AOC not attending I
did read that Aviator x-23 happy belated
David loved the show very informative
and helpful to keep up with the news of
the day and get a progressive
perspective also go pens Rubin gazer
says if you had to if you really had you
who would you rather kiss Mike Pence er
Mitch McConnell this kiss would certify
Bernie as president I had to kiss pen
sir McConnell I don't know I don't even
know I mean it just it doesn't really
make any difference to me there's Ivanka
Trump Jared Kushner coming in who else
is there
that's Lara Trump or one of the other
Trump women we see action happening in
the House chamber and we are expecting
Donald Trump to arrive relatively soon
let me say thanks to atomic Monsta 93
for subscribing with twitch prime you
were twitch subscriber 855 855 we would
love to get to 900 twitch subscribers
this evening let me also say thanks to
Peter sand or Peter sand or is new
member number four and we will see
number four pop up and the bar moves it
moves across thanks Peter really
appreciate your support feel free to
join Peter with that coupon code 36
today krithia says with a twitch Prime
subscription kiss pence so he has to ECT
himself Thank You krithia your
subscriber 856 on twitch matt mauser
says this does the DNC debacle help
Bernie because he isn't associated with
the establishment and this situation
plays into the hands of Trump I think
it's too early to say who the Iowa
situation benefits it's not too early to
say that it's really bad for Biden it's
really really bad for Biden J Square 83
subscribes with twitch prime and says
keep up the good work David J Square 83
you have also triggered a hype train on
twitch yesterday we reached level 4 in
the hype train
I say let's go for level five today it
would be a beautiful thing
pair tearin' says just saw it Congrats
on eight hundred thousand YouTube
subscribers and your birthday yeah I had
this is kind of funny I had a conference
call today with my YouTube rep and we
were just going over you know what did
well what didn't do so well in 2019 he
congratulated me on my 800,000
subscribers as we see Rand Paul here and
he he said he read to me some of my own
youtube titles and it was so funny
hearing them like in a serious context
because when we make these youtube
titles we're kind of joking you know
it's all shock satirical this person
owned that person destroyed he said you
know one of your clips that did really
well was a Trump's brain malfunction
spews nonsense during interview and he
says this completely seriously and I
just start laughing hysterically during
our phone call and then you said you
know one that didn't do so well because
it's not really brand safe was Trump
child rape is back and I said yeah I can
understand why that one did not do so
well we see video of Jared Kushner
talking to you know one of the looks
like the invited guests who are often in
that upper mezzanine looks like there
are some members of various Armed Forces
there as well often a crutch for both
Republican and Democratic presidents to
call out to and tell a story about we
will see if Trump is able to hold it
together despite sniffing and all that
you see Donald Trump now making that
left turn and getting to the front of
the US Capitol 15 minutes still until
the scheduled entrance of Donald Trump
into the house chamber but we will soon
see Donald Trump step out of his of his
limousine let me say thank you and
welcome to Michael Wright Michael Wright
is new member number five of the evening
and Daniel LOI is new member number six
Michael taking advantage of the coupon
code 36 today but that is not mandatory
and Daniel opted to pay full price which
of course we always appreciate you no
matter what you decide to pay for a
membership other super chats coming in
duo Tommy Adams has a good question do
we get uppers Trump or Downers Trump
tonight will we break 100
remember I invite you to check out my
Trump 2020 so do bingo card I tweeted
this this morning so scroll back at D
Pakman on Twitter and I invite you to
play along you will notice that we have
speech slurring there but also where is
sniffing wait a second I have sniffing
Oh constant sniffing so both slurring
his speech and constant sniffing our
squares on the bingo card let's listen
to Nancy Pelosi here so you know what we
don't even care about this this is all
procedural and I'm not I want to talk to
you guys I'm not going to worry about it
let me say thanks to chat FM 22 who
subscribed with prime will pull the
audio back up when the the speak the
sergeant-at-arms announces the arrival
of President Donald Trump bad luck James
sends a super chat love the coverage
David shout out bread mein I guess I did
Britney Kramer is a soy boy level
Youtube subscriber Thank You Britney
Sherri Christopher is also signed up at
the soy boy level hold on a second
things scrolled past Donna Williams
sends a super chat Adam Waddington says
God bless the United structural
the United States of America will he
mention the Israeli city of Jerusalem
tonight I am or the Palestinians I want
to hear all of it Adrian benningfield is
a new YouTube member Kimberly M is a
YouTube member
I love the YouTube memberships but just
in case people are confused the target
of 50 is for website memberships at join
pakman.com not the youtube ones it's for
the website memberships just a reminder
so someone for example who signed up for
a website membership is Marie kazna
Marie hasni is new member number 7
Patrick Smith is new member number 8
Kendricks Phillips is new member number
9 Michael Prindle is new
number ten tyka Webster thanks ty Iike
Taha'a new member number 11
Alex Ringgold is new member number 12
really appreciate your support thank you
so much the coupon code is in honor of
my birthday it was my birthday two days
ago I turned 36 so the code is 36 today
and that is why you save 60% michael
weiner sends a super chat Arno Mitter
knocked sends a super Chat casiano
Battaglia back again thanks Cassiano
Cassiano has been a supporter big li big
li casiano how many times Trump says
witch-hunt could be a game yeah you know
every but everything people are saying
is on my bingo board you can find this
on my Twitter page at the Pakman
witch-hunt is in the upper right corner
so everything I'm seeing in the comments
that Trump might say so far I put on my
bingo board which I generated but with
help from the audience so I'm not
patting myself on the back of course
let's see Andrew Dwyer says is not
attending the State of the Union and
effective way to protest not really I
don't think so you just you're just not
there and you know it's mentioned but
it's not really a big thing
Onis says shouldn't we boycott this
Trump wants the ratings listen Trump
wants the ratings but if you're watching
on an independent progressive YouTube
channel like this one it's doing nothing
for Trump and it's not showing up in the
ratings you're just supporting me by
watching here so I appreciate that
let's see stun ever one of your bingo
squares could be drops dead of a
coronary maybe Rush Limbaugh's
contagious here's hoping when did I get
so toxic yeah I talked about rush
limbaugh having lung cancer on the bonus
show today I think the guy is totally
toxic politically I wouldn't wish that
on anybody and I feel bad for the guy I
don't want anybody to have lung cancer
not not even my worst enemy let me say
thank you to know to nobody else I
thought I had someone else to thank for
a website membership in comes someone
let's see what's going on
[Music]
mild applause for the Dean of the
diplomatic corps we will absolutely get
over to the audio as soon as Donald
Trump has arrived if you were just
joining us on twitch please make sure
you are following my channel if you are
just joining on youtube please hit the
like button we we would love to get to a
thousand likes before the speech starts
in 10 minutes the likes are really
helpful to us and they help get more
people into the stream and right after
hitting like I have just one other small
request make sure to subscribe to my
youtube channel we had an amazing night
yesterday beautiful night where we
surpassed 800,000 YouTube subscribers
and got a lot of congratulations today
from people in the audience and I would
I would love it if you not only hit the
like button Wow it's like a it's like a
slot machine it's going up very quickly
hit the like button but also hit
subscribe because that that really is a
big thing for us it's free it's
completely free let's see here other
super chats that are coming in Matt and
says I did cover my twenty dollar
mistake last time so I'm doing it right
okay thank you Matt Trisha Pena art says
appreciate all you do I appreciate you
being here Trisha I appreciate that
Zelda freak 22 says happy birthday David
any predictions
I predict Trump attacks socialism and
probably there's Jerry Nadler and Zoe
Lofgren by the way Jared Kushner there
next to Ivanka Trump remember Trump
famously saying that if Ivanka weren't
his daughter he would be interested in
dating her that's what the President of
the United States once said I predict
that there will be a lot of sniffing and
maybe a lot of dissembling by Donald
Trump thanks to Shawn is crazy for
subscribing with twitch prime thanks to
zip zabba KY 22 for subscribing with
twitch prime you too there's Adam Schiff
you to our subscribers 859 and 860 on
twitch which I appreciate
Seth van rook says opened the bingo card
on Photoshop I'm ready yeah
the bingo card is on my twitch page oh
that's
Kyrsten Sinema by the way this is the
bingo follow me on twitter at D Pakman
you will see the bingo card there are 25
it's really 24 squares and a free square
pay attention I want to know I am
expecting from you guys that if and when
bingo is hit people will put it in the
chat because I actually do think that
bingo will is likely with everything
that we've got going on here so that's
on my on my Twitter page at D Pakman a
Calvin Bartlett has subscribed on
YouTube thanks Calvin
our no mitr nacht says why is the
Republican Party protected protecting
Trump besides his tweets I don't know
whether that I understand that why are
they protecting him beside his tweets I
apologize that I'm not sure what you
mean
Troy Mackin Roy says congratulations on
800,000 dude thank you I appreciate it
Erik Stifler hey Erik Zoey I hope you
feel better soon
all right cat alot says where do you
prefer membership including patreon we
keep the largest share of payments on
our website you know YouTube takes a cut
and twitch takes a cut all that stuff we
keep the biggest portion on our website
so that is that is a good place to sign
up and on that note I want to say thanks
to Adam Clark Adam Clark is new member
number 13 today as you can see we have a
target of 50 website members we have
gotten 13 of them and the coupon code is
36 today in honor of my birthday this is
the Supreme Court entering as you can
see Chief Justice John Roberts you see
Elena Kagan behind John Roberts and
other people they cut away they will sit
near the front as do the generals as
Donald Trump likes to refer to them
other super chats coming in Adana
Williams says I hope stormy Daniels
shows up that would be amazing if a
Democrat had stormy Daniels is again
I would love it mark Hess says David
your show is the future of web news keep
it up what do you think of Trump's
increased approval rating and how it
will affect November of 2020 I believe
that between the the disaster in Iowa
combined with Trump's upcoming acquittal
it is very reasonable that Donald Trump
may sail to re-election although I hope
not we are about five minutes away from
the entrance of Donald Trump into the
chamber I hope you will play bingo along
with us there is a bingo card on my
Twitter page at D Pakman where you can
find it I am particularly interested in
seeing if Donald Trump refers to his
perfect phone call which is a square I
want to see if he talks about mini Mike
meeting mini Mike Bloomberg does he
point to a black person in the crowd and
refer to them as my african-american as
he once did and does the name Pocahontas
get mentioned those are my bingo items
that I am most curious about whether we
will see or hear from Donald Trump today
if you were just joining us on YouTube I
see a few hundred more people have just
joined welcome I am so glad that you're
here and that you're going to be
watching the State of the Union address
with me or better said I am going to be
watching it with you make sure to hit
the like button we are just a hundred
and forty likes from a thousand on this
stream and the likes really do help get
more people in the audience and also
make sure to subscribe to the David
Pakman show YouTube channel we hit 800
thousand subscribers yesterday which is
crazy
all sorts of congratulations came in
including from my YouTube rep there is
Senator Kamala Harris if I was if I were
Kamala Harris and I saw what took place
in the Iowa caucus yesterday I might
regret having gotten out when I did and
I respect her for doing it because her
campaign was imploding
but given the failure of Biden at least
in the results that we have so far which
are here pete Budaj edge becoming the
sort of establishment candid
de facto it could have been Kamala
Harris it could have been calmly
Harrison I wonder if she is regretting
having gotten out there is Joaquin
Castro not who Leon Castro that Joaquin
Castro the twin brother of course of who
Leon we are expecting the president's
entrance entrance any moment now Patrick
a Smith has signed up on YouTube thanks
Patrick that fast scroll happen again
Prairie rubbish says say what you want
about Trump when you're stoned he's the
funniest man alive even better than W
and he was epic I don't disagree some of
the stuff Trump tweets like tweeting
that Mike Bloomberg is negotiating
standing in a box during debates that's
hilarious that is genuinely hilarious
it's completely unpresidential
but it is very very funny let me say
thanks to runner 3:54 for subscribing
with twitch prime & söhne digital for
subscribing with twitch prime very much
appreciate that we are just minutes from
Donald Trump's entrance into the house
chamber I am taking super chat questions
and twitch subscription questions until
then the best way to support these
streams is always just grab a membership
on my website this is really cheap you
know you you might not know it but with
your cable TV subscription you're giving
two bucks a month to Fox News already
you can throw us a couple bucks a month
instead by subscribing at join
pakman.com I don't even need you to pay
full price it was my birthday on Sunday
we have a coupon code celebrating my
birthday the code is 36 today it'll save
you 50% and then I will I will thank you
pro few Slee on stream if you sign up at
join pakman.com in comes Melania Trump
there is a heavily bearded guy behind
her doing a lot of clapping we see I
believe that that's Tiffany Trump on our
right
lera Trump on our left Jared Kushner is
there Melania Trump making her way to
her seat shaking hands with a guy who no
doubt will be the subject of at least
one anecdote from Donald Trump today no
question about it I am being told that
due to a
Xplosive demand for memberships the
website is extremely slow we've dealt
with that issue before during streams
it's a good problem to have
let me go ahead and just reboot the
website and I apologize to people
physically struggling to get memberships
I'm going to get it fixed for you right
now and I I do apologize for that
okay should be back up and running very
very soon we were getting very close to
the entrance of Donald Trump still not
yet this is the cabinet of course of
Donald Trump we see Mike Pompeo and
Steve Newton and who else is back there
Pompeyo Secretary of State Steven
minuchin of course the secretary of the
Treasury who else is behind I'm trying
to see there some people I don't
recognize I don't recognize let me say
thank you to Carole Mears Carole Mears
has subscribed join pakman.com and his
new member number 14 you see Mike Pompeo
shaking hands there with Justice John
Roberts that was Attorney General
William bar one of the most corrupt
Attorneys General in a very very long
time we have a sickening group of people
here associated with Donald Trump and
folks it's gonna get much worse if this
guy gets himself reelected I believe who
are we seeing here I believe that's
elaine chao ben Carson we see maybe the
most unqualified Secretary of Education
ever Betsy DeVos who else is coming in
here filing in like the crooks that they
are the corrupt crony capitalists crooks
that they are who else do we see I don't
I don't know who all of these people are
interesting interestingly enough let's
see here yeah I see the super chats
about trouble on the website I have just
rebooted the website and it should be
clear for you to go ahead and grab a
membership now I just rebooted it and I
believe that the performance should be
improving drastically high demand during
these streams because
the number of people trying to grab
memberships I'm aware of it
let's see mantra light of mantra light
of angels says how many glitches will
Trump have tonight I'm curious myself
I'm curious myself how many glitches we
will see from Trump how off-script will
de Mount mango menace KO asks valve from
Agawam I think Trump will actually stay
on script today there's Cory Booker
I believe that's uh that Blumenthal on
the left that's definitely Melania Trump
that I know Christopher hatch says catch
the wave WH a V Merrimack Valley
beautiful stun ever who is the
designated survivor tonight I don't know
that's a good question usually there is
someone selected to not be here in case
the worst might happen and everybody
gets killed I mean it's it's it's a grim
but that's why they do it and I don't
know who the designated survivor is
today Harrison Jordan says looking
forward to a night full of brain
malfunctions Dante Geese says favorite
thing about Trump sorry for the hard
tasks his funny tweets I mean I find
some of his tweets absolutely hilarious
alright let's see I am told that the
website is sort of back up and running I
am told there's also a minute left until
that reboot is completely finished but
yeah the websites getting hammered right
now thanks to the demand for memberships
I apologize I really do but we are we
are working to get it back up as quickly
as possible
Donald Trump should be entering any
moment let's get live audio here any
moment the sergeant-at-arms will come in
and introduce the President of the
United States
Laurette stone says happy birthday David
Waller is me so sorry if you address
this do you believe there's a decent
chance the caucus debacle was partially
intentionally played out by the DNC I am
not ready to say that at this point in
time I want to be careful about saying
saying something I don't have evidence
for there is the sergeant-at-arms
Paul something I believe is his name or
Pete and there is Donald Trump and they
are about ready to get started let's
take a listen
madam Speaker the President of the
United States
let's see who is and is not flapping
here
it looks like down their trunk from what
I'm seeing so far it does look like down
in front
[Applause]
[Music]
the IRS with our governor or an animal
shelter that's cool
[Applause]
Donald Trump continuing to make his way
in
[Applause]
from saying something to Don Roberts who
of course is about to preside over
Donovan's acquitted in the Senate
impeachment trial
[Applause]
this is alpha male hump feeling his
stance now it's weird like if you're
Nancy Pelosi and you think this guy
should be impeached
why do you [ __ ] it just doesn't make any
sense I don't get it why even bother to
coral the coral
thanks to Jasper and Sandy Jasper and
Sandhya's new member number 15 today
keep those new members coming up very
very excited
and I am told the website is back up
this is a good opportunity to grab those
memberships people Avenger black kill
made gaming says commander-in-chief Jack
Sparrow is about to speak Judah's new
David trying to get onto your website to
become a member but having trouble the
website should be back up I am told
Nancy Pelosi no the President of the
United States certainly more muted
applause than we are used to seem and in
fact it looks like the Democratic side
is not copping an answer to Loki's
introduction that is a departure from
the standard the core and that you see
doing these if I'm looking at that
correctly
[Applause]
and as predicted 907 p.m. as I said from
going into it madam speaker mr. vice
president members of Congress the first
lady of the United States
I'll give me a break
at my fellow-citizens three years ago we
launched the great American comeback
tonight I stand before you to share the
incredible results oh god it's gonna be
hard to factor booming incomes are
soaring poverty is plummeting crime is
falling confidence is surging and our
country is thriving and highly respected
again that is untrue he is sniffing
though you can check off sniffing on the
bingo group thanks to RJ Rodrigo and
rather play the new subscriptions I
appreciate that as well as the sentient
America's enemies are on the run
America's its fortunes are on the rise
in America's future is blazing bright
the years of economic decay are over
quick back Tecla stuck
excuse me the stock market is
underperforming the stock market under
Barack Obama during the first three
years and one week of presidency from
stock markets under country being used
taken advantage of and even scorned by
other nations are long behind us these
lives are even more rapid than most
similarly broken promises jobless
recoveries tired platitudes and constant
excuses for the depletion of American
wealth power and prestige in just three
short years we have shattered the
mentality of American decline and we
have rejected the downsizing of
Americans destiny we have totally
rejected the downsizing nothing Adler
moving forward at a pace that was
unimaginable just a short time ago and
we are never ever going back
dear God
Nancy Pelosi paging you tonight that our
economy is the best it has ever been our
military is completely rebuilt with its
power being unmatched anywhere in the
world and it's not even close our
borders are secure our families are
flourishing our values are renewed our
pride is restored and for all of these
reasons I say to the people of our great
country and to the members of Congress
the state of our union is stronger than
ever before if our borders are secure
why do we need the law
[Applause]
the vision I will lay out this evening
demonstrates how we are building the
world's most prosperous and inclusive
society one where every citizen can join
in America's unparalleled success and
where every community can take part in
America's extraordinary rise from the
instant I took office I moved rapidly to
revive the US economy slashing a record
number of job-killing regulations
enacting historic and record-setting tax
cuts and fighting for fair and
reciprocal trade agreements
yikes
both yikes
our agenda is relentlessly pro-worker
pro-family pro-growth and most of all
pro-american imagine seeing this stuff
and feeling good about it right like I
wish I was not the reason well I really
do
thank you there's Debbie we are
advancing with unbridled optimism and
lifting our citizens of every race color
religion and Creed very very high since
my election we have created 7 million
new jobs 5 million more than government
experts projected during the previous
administration that's such a confusing
statement that it will just get too late
applause people say I don't get that but
I'll clap with that
did anybody get is the lowest in over
half a century and very incredibly the
average unemployment rate under my
administration is lower than any
Administration in the history of our
country even Republicans don't believe
this [ __ ]
jean-robert might as well pack right
like the game is over we no gun you know
if we hadn't reversed the failed
economic policies of the previous
administration the world would not now
be witnessing this great economic
success
[Music]
the unemployment rate for
african-americans Hispanic Americans
that's on my fingers has reached the
lowest levels in history there it is
like you're playing along
african-american youth unemployment has
reached an all-time low double bingo
african-american poverty has declined to
the lowest rate ever recorded identity
politics the unemployment rate for women
reached the lowest level in almost 70
years and last year women filled 72
percent of all new jobs added I love my
[ __ ] pretending that he likes that
the veterans unemployment rate dropped
to a record low
the unemployment rate for disabled
Americans has reached an all-time low
workers without a high school diploma
have achieved the lowest unemployment
rate recorded in US history
a record number of young Americans are
now employed and the recommend or
unemployed and the population goes up
focus tration more than 10 million
people were added to the Food Stamp
rolls under my administration seven
million Americans have come off food
stamps and ten million people have been
lifted off of welfare to say people have
come off of food stamps doesn't mean
much if you simply cut the program and
kick them on right that's like saying
we've taken ten people off of life
support today well did they die or did
they come off off life support because
they don't need it anymore
it eight years under the last
administration over 300,000 working age
people dropped out of the workforce in
just three years of my administration
3.5 million people working age people
have joined the workforce
since my election the net worth of the
bottom half of wage earners has
increased by 47 percent three times
faster than the increase for the top one
percent
after decades of flat and falling
incomes wages are rising fast and
wonderfully they are rising fastest for
low-income workers who have seen a 16
percent pay increase since my election
that is maybe the most perceptive stat
so far I have to break it down tomorrow
some of this is just made up this is a
blue-collar boom look at who got the
lion's share of the tax cuts and say
that it with a straight face my friend
real median household income is now at
the highest level ever recorded since my
election u.s. stock markets have soared
70 percent adding more than 12 trillion
dollars to our nation's wealth
transcending anything anyone believed
was possible this is a record it is
something that every country in the
world is looking up to they admire
remember I ran the numbers attendance is
better under Obama's first three years
in the stock market just reached amazing
new highs all of those millions of
people with 401ks and pensions are doing
far better than they have ever done
before with increases of 60 70 80 90 and
100 percent and even more jobs and
investments are pouring in to nine
thousand previously neglected
neighborhoods
thanks to Opportunity Zones a plan
spearheaded by senator Tim Scott
[Applause]
working tax cars oh dear
there's Lindsay Looney Lindsay and
Lankford this guy right here is lovely
he's one of the craziest senators out
there in other words wealthy people and
companies are pouring money into poor
neighborhoods or areas that haven't seen
investment in many decades creating jobs
energy and excitement
this is the first time that these
deserving communities have seen anything
like this it's all working Opportunity
Zones are helping Americans like Army
veteran tony Rankin's
from Cincinnati Ohio after struggling
with drug addiction here we go Tony lost
his job his house and his family he was
homeless but then Tony found a
construction company that invests and
Opportunity Zones Oh put him right now a
top tradesman drug-free reunited with
his family and he is here tonight Tony
keep up the great work Tony this
pandering is best that that poor guy
all hail king Trump right
thank you Tony era roaring economy has
for the first time ever given many
former prisoners the ability to get a
great job and a fresh start the second
chance at life is made possible because
we passed landmark criminal justice
reform into law everybody said that
criminal justice reform couldn't be done
but I got it done and the people in this
room got it done everybody cheered for
themselves stand up and cure for
yourself please
[Applause]
humors like I'm still voting to convict
but I'll cheerfully
thanks to our bold regulatory reduction
campaign the United States has become
the number-one producer of oil and
natural gas anywhere in the world
that's a bad thing that's not good we
don't want that at that
with the tremendous progress we have
made over the past three years America
is now energy independent and energy
jobs like so many other elements of Oh
careful there pence already ready finish
the line
the puppeteer is very busy this is the
sick
we are doing numbers that no one would
have thought possible just three years
ago likewise we are restoring our
nation's manufacturing might even though
predictions were as you all know that
this could never ever be done after
losing 60,000 factories under the
previous two administrations America has
now gained twelve anthe can't believe
that reason to my administration with
thousands upon thousands of plants and
factories being planned or being built
[Applause]
Nancy Pelosi is like how many more pages
of this crap are we gonna have to sit
there
companies are not leaving they are
coming back to the USA those reliance
people ask me how long it'll go is that
everybody wants to be where the action
is in the United States of America is
indeed the place where the action is to
375 about promises I made to the
American people was to replace the
disastrous NAFTA trade deal
[Applause]
in fact unfair trade is perhaps the
single biggest reason that I decided to
run for president he figured out he
could trick people adoption our nation
lost one in four manufacturing jobs many
politicians came and went pledging to
change or replace NAFTA only to do so
and then absolutely nothing happened but
unlike so many who came before me I keep
my promises we did our job what happened
to the wall what happened to pay off the
debt what I mean is you've got to be an
idiot inside the brand-new US Mexico
Canada agreement into law the u.s. MCA
will create nearly 100,000 new
high-paying American auto jobs and
massively boost exports for our farmers
ranchers and factory workers if people
wants the great fear about whether they
want to [ __ ] that
it will also bring trade with Mexico and
Canada to a much higher level but also
to be a much greater degree of fairness
and reciprocity we will have that
fairness and reciprocity and I say that
finally because it's been many many
years that we were treated fairly on
trade this is the first major trade deal
in many years to earn the strong backing
of America's labor unions citizens that
I would impose tariffs to confront
China's massive theft of America's jobs
our strategy has worked notice it's 37
degrees and he's discussing that will
defend our workers protect our
intellectual property bring billions and
billions of dollars into our treasury
and open vast new markets for products
made and grown right here in the USA
[Applause]
for decades China has taken advantage of
the United States now we have changed
that but at the same time we have
perhaps the best relationship we've ever
had with China including with President
Xi they respect what we've done because
quite frankly they could never really
believe that they were able to get away
with what they were doing
year after year decade after decade
without anyone in our country stepping
up and saying that's enough
[Applause]
the overeager cracking Republicans are
in country and that's exactly what we're
doing we are rebuilding our country as
we restore he's starting to look at this
it's starting we are once again standing
up for freedom in our hemisphere that's
why my administration reversed the
failing policies of the previous
administration on Cuba idiotic reversal
we are supporting the hopes of Cubans
Nicaraguans and Venezuelans to restore
democracy the United States is leading a
59 Nation diplomatic coalition against
the socialist dictator of Venezuela
Nicolas Maduro
everybody can agree on that
Maduro is an illegitimate ruler a tyrant
who brutalizes his people but maduras
grip and tyranny will be smashed and
broken here this evening it's a very
brave man who carries with him the hopes
dreams and aspirations of all
Venezuelans did they bring a refugee
joining us in the gallery is the true
and legitimate president of Venezuela oh
dear whydo mr. president oh dear God
this is a geopolitical disaster disaster
well we're meddling folks we're meddling
this is bad
module is portable but the u.s. can't be
doing this Thank You mr. president
great honor thank you very much please
take this message back that all
Americans are united with the Venezuelan
people in their righteous struggle for
freedom thank you very much mr.
president
that's true but we can't be involved
guys we can't be in bad
this is terrible another innovation
Klump might have had a perfect poem
ecology to this guy
thank you very much socialism destroys
nations this is on my fingers remember
freedom unifies the soul to safeguard
American liberty we have invested a
record-breaking 2.2 trillion dollars in
the United States military
spending money on the military yeah
remember if we don't clap it on
patriotic we have purchased the finest
planes missiles rocket ships in every
other form of military equipment and
it's all made right here in the USA
I have some arms dealers in the crowd we
are also getting our allies finally to
help pay their fair share
[Applause]
I have raised contributions from other
NATO members by more than 400 billion
dollars and the number of allies meeting
their minimum obligations has more than
doubled and just weeks ago for the first
time since President Truman established
the air force more than 70 years earlier
we created a brand new branch of the
United States Armed Forces it's called
the space force and we copied the logo
from star very important
let's bomb stuff in outer space now
the generals actually looked a little
bit skeptical at the spaceport in the
gallery tonight we have a young
gentleman and what he wants so badly 13
years old
Ian laun Faye he's an eighth grader from
Arizona Ian please stand up
ian has always dreamed of going to space
he was the first of his class and among
the youngest at an aviation academy he
aspires to go to the Air Force Academy
and then he has his eye on the space
force as he and says most people look up
at space I want to look down on the
world it kind of looks like I looked at
anything
with the kids just interested in space
like he seems like a great kid but
what's his presence here justified by I
don't even understand
but sitting behind Ian tonight is his
greatest hero of them all
Charles Magee was born in Cleveland Ohio
one century ago Charles is one of the
last surviving Tuskegee Airmen the first
black fighter pilots and he also happens
to be his great grandfather that's kind
of cool and interesting
this is all pretty weird I'm not gonna
lie
strangely infertile
credible story after more than 130
combat missions in World War two
he came back home to a country still
struggling for civil rights and went on
to serve America in Korea and Vietnam on
December 7th Charles celebrated his
100th birthday
how does Trump tie this into his policy
other than space force right I mean
that's it's a very interesting story
that the Stiggy airmen it's fascinating
but usually there's a tie in other than
we're gonna bomb [ __ ] in space a few
weeks ago assigned a bill promoting
Charles McGee to Brigadier General and
earlier today I pinned the stars on his
shoulders in the Oval Office General
McGee our nation salutes you thank you
sir
so it's self aggrandizing it's I did
this thing
from the pilgrims to the founders from
the soldiers at Valley Forge to the
marchers at Selma and from President
Lincoln to the Reverend Martin Luther
King from the KKK Onassis limits on our
children's future members of Congress we
must never forget that the only
victories that matter in Washington or
victories that deliver for the American
people and I am the opposite of the
embodiment of that idea yeah now they're
sick having a hard time without
the people are the heart of our country
their dreams are the soul of our country
and their love is what powers and
sustains our country we must always
remember that our job is to put America
first
you can say it doesn't make it real
the next step forward in building an
inclusive society is making sure that
every young American gets a great
education and the opportunity to achieve
the American dream
yet for too long countless American
children have been trapped in failing
government schools to rescue these
students 18 states have created school
choice in the form of opportunity
scholarship the programs are so popular
that tens of thousands of students
remain on a waiting list one of those
students is Jenaya davis a fourth grader
from Philadelphia I think everybody
understands the pandering that's going
on
[Applause]
Jenai is mom Stephanie is a single
parent she would do anything to give her
daughter a better future but last year
that future was put further out of reach
when Pennsylvania's governor vetoed
legislation to expand school choice to
50,000 children Jenna and Stephanie are
in the gallery Stephanie thank you so
much for being here with your beautiful
daughter thank you very much anybody
else finding it weird that as nice as
I'm sure these people are it's not like
they've really done something that ties
into Tom policy they're props with some
to criticize people
but you know I have some good news for
you because I am pleased to inform you
that your long wait is over I can
proudly announce tonight that an
opportunity scholarship has become
available it's going to you and you will
soon be heading to the school of your
choice
these are props but from cipa fencing
now I call on Congress to give 1 million
American children the same opportunity
Jenaya has just received passed the
education freedom scholarships and
opportunities Act because no parent
should be forced to send their child to
a failing government school bad
government school Betsy device may be
the most clueless Secretary of Education
in this country's history and we've had
some clueless people in fact every young
person should have a safe and secure
environment in which to learn and to
grow for this reason our magnificent
first lady has launched the b-best
initiative yes advance a safe healthy
supportive and drug-free life she's
against bullying which daily online in
school and in our communities Thank You
Melania for your extraordinary love and
profound care for America's children
thank you seem skeptical of my
accompanist thank you very first one no
relationship there I think they refer to
each other is certain
I'm cringing guys I'm cringing my
administration is determined to give our
citizens the opportunities they need
regardless of age or background through
our pledge to American workers over 400
companies will also provide new jobs and
education opportunities to almost 15
million Americans my budget also
contains an exciting vision for our
nation's high schools tonight I ask
Congress to support our students and
backed by plan to offer vocational and
technical education in every single high
school in America
to expand equal opportunity I am also
proud that we achieved record and
permanent funding for our nation's
historically black colleges and
universities
it's just really milquetoast applause
bones
a good life for American families also
requires the most affordable innovative
and high quality health care system on
earth let's see what he says before I
took office health insurance premiums
had more than doubled in just five years
oh now I move quickly to provide
affordable alternatives
this has to be Alliance are up to 60%
less expensive and better this is a
these are straight-up fabrication easy
just like
website is working now by the way folks
I've seen you member flips coming in I
see some people saying I've also made an
ironclad pledge to American families we
will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions actually
Obamacare did that oh that that's
hilarious Obamacare
and we will always protect your Medicare
and we will always protect your Social
Security all where he's proposed cutting
those
the American patient should never be
blindsided by medical bills that is why
I signed an executive order requiring
price transparency
this is shocking many experts believe
that transparency which will go into
full effect at the beginning of next
year will be even bigger than health
care reform it won't nobody need it
we'll save families massive amounts of
money for substantially better care but
as we work to improve Americans health
care there are those who want to take
away your health care yeah your doctor
and abolish private insurance entirely
132 lawmakers in this room have endorsed
legislation to impose a socialist
takeover of our health care system
wiping out the private health insurance
plans of 180 million very happy
Americans
no one's clapping for that because
everyone knows nobody's happy I want you
to know we will never let socialism
destroy American there's the line
remember folks if you're playing around
or playing along so do bingo socialism
does the top left I put this together
this morning I think someone must have
bingo Boehner he's hit everything so far
over 130 legislators in this chamber
have endorsed legislation that would
bankrupt our nation by providing free
taxpayer-funded health care to millions
of illegal aliens losing taxpayers to
subsidize free care for any one node
lawfully crosses our borders these
proposals would raid the Medicare
benefits of our seniors and that our
seniors depend on which he wants to cut
anyway is a powerful lure for illegal
immigration that is what is happening in
California and other states their
systems are totally out of control
costing taxpayers vast and unaffordable
amounts of money
I think that's bingo yeah if forcing
American taxpayers to provide unlimited
free health care to illegal aliens
sounds fair to you then stand with the
radical left but if you believe that we
should defend American patients and
American seniors then stand with me and
pass legislation to prohibit free
government healthcare for illegal aliens
how about getting people half
have what about that
[Applause]
this will be a tremendous boon to our
already very strongly guarded southern
border where as we speak a long tall and
very powerful wall is being built that
is also on my bingo card we are building
the wall Wow Wow
we have now completed over 100 miles and
have over 500 miles fully completed in a
very short period of time early next
year we will have substantially more
than 500 miles completed my
administration has also taken on the big
pharmaceutical companies we have
approved a race to change topic randal
generic drugs and medicines are being
approved by the FDA at a faster clip
than ever before the kind of those
things that even if it's true it's
genuinely irrelevant because the devil
is in the details if it's even true
right we didn't know and I was pleased
to announce last year that for the first
time in 51 years the costs of
prescription drugs actually went down
some of these are actually getting
Hannah cream these are new talking
points we've not yet working together
Congress can reduce drug prices
substantially from current levels I've
been speaking to Senator Chuck Grassley
of Iowa great guy and others in Congress
in order to get something on drug
pricing done and done quickly and
properly I'm calling for bipartisan
legislation that achieves the goal of
dramatically lowering prescription drug
prices get a bill on my desk and I will
sign it into law immediately in your
April
[Applause]
ben Carson is very very sleepy
we got to get him home guys
here's a dictionary to go read
oh there's a protest now we're nearly
there is now a protest ladies and
gentlemen this is the moment of protest
we were wondering if it would happen
drug overdose deaths declined for the
first time in nearly 30 years among the
states hardest hit Ohio is down 22%
Pennsylvania is down 18% I've noticed
listen is down 10% and we will not quit
until we have beaten the opioid epidemic
once and for all
they'll bomb it if he has to he's gonna
beat that opioid epidemic and the
submission doesn't matter who he's got a
bribe or who he's got a bomb
protecting Americans health also means
fighting infectious diseases we are
coordinating with the Chinese government
and working closely together so we are
worthy corona virus outbreak in China
China's charities will take all
necessary steps to safeguard our
citizens from things we've got
everything we have the earnest ambitious
new initiatives to substantially improve
care for Americans with kidney disease
Alzheimer's and those struggling with
mental health and because Congress was
so good as to fund my request new cures
for childhood cancer and we will
eradicate the AIDS epidemic in America
by the end of this decade
almost every American family knows the
pain when a loved one is diagnosed with
a serious illness here tonight is a
special man beloved by millions of
Americans who just received a stage four
breast cancer diagnosis this is not good
news but what is good news is that he is
the greatest fighter and winner that you
will ever meet rush limbaugh thank you
for your decades of tireless devotion to
our country
and rush in recognition of all that you
have done for our nation the millions of
people a day that you speak to and that
you inspire and all of the incredible
work that you have done for charity I am
proud to announce tonight that you will
be receiving our country's highest
civilian honor now the Presidential
Medal of Freedom
yeah he's he doesn't even think that
makes any sense
he's like this can't be right
I will now ask the First Lady of the
United States to present you own a honor
play you're doing it now
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
and this is something else
Nancy Pelosi oh just looking away I mean
it's Italy this is business
this is very cozy
Russ and Catherine congratulations Thank
You Catherine as we pray for all who are
sick we know that America is constantly
achieving new medical breakthroughs in
2017 doctors at st. Luke's Hospital in
Kansas City delivered one of the
earliest premature babies ever to
survive born adjust 21 weeks in six days
and weighing less than a pound ellie
schneider was a born fighter through the
skill of her doctors and the prayers of
her parents little ellie kept on winning
the battle of life Ellie's death is a
strong healthy two-year-old girl sitting
with her amazing mother Robin in the
gallery Ellie and Robin we're glad to
have you with us tonight
le reminds us that every child is a
miracle of life and thanks to modern
medical wonders 50% of very premature
babies delivered at the hospital where
le was born now survived it's an
incredible thing thank you very much you
know it's like that's great
none of this has anything to do with I'm
sure that every baby has the best chance
to thrive and grow just like le that is
why I'm asking Congress to provide an
additional 50 million dollars to fund
neonatal research for America's youngest
patients
that is why I'm also calling upon
members of Congress here tonight we rest
legislation finally banning the late
term abortion of babies okay so she's
the right way
um something about this experience I
don't know exactly what it is but it's
like
and peril sick
whether we're Republican Democrat or
independent surely we must all agree
that every human life is a sacred gift
from God as we support America's moms
and dads I was recently proud to serve
as an atheist the law of providing new
parents in the federal workforce paid
family leave serving as a model for the
rest of the country
now I call on Congress to pass the
bipartisan advancing support for working
families Act extending family leave to
mothers and fathers all across our
nation
40 million American families have an
average 2200 dollars extra thanks to our
child tax credit
now important to understand many have
lost money from other changes to the
taxpayer I've also overseen historic
funding increases for high quality child
care enabling 17 states to help more
children many of which have reduced or
eliminated their wait lists altogether
and I sent Congress a plan with a vision
to further expand access to high-quality
child care and urge you to act
immediately to protect the environment
days ago I announced that the United
States will join the 1 trillion trees
initiative an ambitious effort to bring
together government and private sector
2.1 million trees in America and all
around the world
we must also rebuild America's
infrastructure something we can agree on
right except you want to do it with
crony method contacts to his friends you
win some you lose
I asked you to pass senator John
Burroughs highway bill to invest in new
roads bridges and tunnels all across our
land
I'm also committed to ensuring that
every citizen can have access to
high-speed Internet including and
especially in rural America
they better tomorrow for all Americans
also requires us to keep America safe
that means supporting the men and women
of law enforcement at every level
including our nation's heroic ice
officers let's see if we can do some
profiling of dangerous Hispanics here I
think they'll be able to work it in
particularly if Steven Miller's been
involved in this speech Nancy Pelosi
surfaces arrested more than 120,000
criminal aliens charged with nearly
10,000 burglaries there go 5,000 sexual
assaults 45,000 violent assaults and
2,000 murders tragically there are many
cities in America where radical
politicians have chosen to provide
sanctuary for these criminal illegal
aliens in sanctuary cities local
officials order police to release
dangerous criminal aliens to prey upon
the public instead of handing them over
to ice to be safely removed oh boy just
29 days ago a criminal alien freed by
the sanctuary city of New York was
charged with the brutal rape and murder
of a 92 year old woman
the killer had been previously arrested
for assault but under New York sanctuary
policies he was set free if the city had
honored ices detainer request his victim
would still be alive today the state of
California passed an outrageous law
declaring their whole state to be a
stationary for criminal
it's the sanctuary guys it's an attack
on police it's terrible sanctuary with
catastrophic results here is just one
tragic example in December 2018
California police detained an illegal
alien with five prior arrests including
convictions for robbery and assault
but as required by California's
sanctuary law local authorities released
him days later the criminal alien went
on a gruesome spree of deadly violence
he viciously shot one man going about
his daily work he approached a woman
sitting in her car and shot her in the
arm and in the chest he walked into a
convenience store and wildly fired his
weapon he hijacked a truck and smashed
into vehicles critically injuring
innocent victims one of the victims is a
terrible terrible situation died fifty
one-year-old American named rocky Jones
rocky was at a gas station when this
vile criminal fired eight bullets at him
from close range murdering him in cold
blood
rocky left behind a devoted family
including his brothers who loved him
more than anything else in the world one
of his grieving brothers is here with us
tonight
Jodie would you please stand Jodie thank
you
Jodee our hearts weep for your loss and
we will not rest until you have justice
senator Tom Tillis has introduced
legislation to allow Americans like Jodi
to sue sanctuary cities and states when
a loved one is hurt or killed as a
result of these deadly practice
you know this person could be cook
talking about gun violence right instead
of doing the same old stuff about
criminal items to pass the justice for
victims of sanctuary cities act
immediately the United States of America
should be a sanctuary for law-abiding
Americans not criminal aliens
[Applause]
dear God
in the last three years Isis arrested
over 5,000 wicked human traffickers when
I have side nine pieces of legislation
to stamp out the Menace of human
trafficking domestically and all around
the globe my administration has
undertaken an unprecedented effort to
secure the southern border of the United
States
before I came into office if you showed
up illegally on our southern border and
were arrested you were simply released
and allowed into our country never to be
seen again
my administration has ended catch and
release
if you come illegally you will now be
promptly removed from our country very
importantly we entered into historic
cooperation agreements with the
governments of Mexico Honduras El
Salvador and Guatemala as a result of
our unprecedented efforts illegal
crossings are down 75% since May
dropping eight straight months in a row
great we don't need the war
and as the wall rapidly goes up drug
seizures rise and the border crossings
are going down and going down very
rapidly last year I traveled to the
border in Texas and met chief patrol
agent Raul Ortiz for months agent Ortiz
and his team have seized more than
200,000 pounds of poisonous narcotics
arrested more than 3,000 human smugglers
was poisoned rescued more than two
thousand migrants days ago agent Ortiz
was promoted to deputy chief of Border
Patrol and he joins us tonight
chief Ortiz please stand
thanks Josh look for the subscription by
the way I do see those animation thanks
you and all of the heroes of Border
Patrol and ice thank you very much to
build on these historic gains we are
working on legislation to replace our
outdated and randomized immigration
system with one based on merit welcoming
those who follow the rules contribute to
our economy support themselves
financially and uphold our values
with every action my administration is
restoring the rule of law and
reasserting the culture of American
freedom muted applause they're working
with Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell oh dear no no no even might
hurt alike today than we've seen his
colleagues in the Senate we have
confirmed a record number of 187 new
federal judges helped to uphold our
Constitution as written this includes
two brilliant new Supreme Court justices
Neill course Festus is starting
Cavanaugh thank you desperate the judges
are arguably the worst things we've done
and we have many in the pipeline we know
this is why we gotta get him out my
administration is also defending
religious liberty and that includes the
constitutional right to pray in public
schools that is very different than
organized prayer panel my friends pray
in your head nobody has to know
organized prayer time is a good thing
King it is established we don't tear
down crosses we don't ban symbols of
faith we don't muzzle preachers and
pastors Muslims in America we celebrate
faith
we cherish religion we lift our voices
in prayer and we raise our sights to the
glory of God just as we believe in the
First Amendment we also believe in
another constitutional right that is
under siege all across our country so
long as I am president I will always
protect your second Amendment right to
keep and bear it's the red meat folks
he's really doing it
he is destroying it out there rah
Nancy Pelosi's burning certain papers
with a lighter in reaffirming our
heritage as a free nation we must
remember that America has always been a
frontier nation interesting yelling now
we must embrace the next frontier Nancy
Pelosi's comments on his manifest
destiny and the Stars I am asking
Congress to fully fund the art of this
program to ensure that the next man and
the first woman on the moon will be
American astronauts using this as a
launch action to ensure that America is
the first nation to plant its flag on
Mars
thanks Jacob for signing up for the
numbers with appreciated as this really
devolved is also strongly defending our
national security and combating radical
Islamic terrorism Tara you need Bernie
last week I announced a groundbreaking
plan for peace between Israel and the
Palestinians yeah that was recognizing
that all past attempts have failed we
must be determined and creative in order
to stabilize the region and give
millions of young people the chance to
realize a better future three years ago
the barbarians of Isis held over 20,000
square miles of territory in Iraq and
Syria today the ISIS territorial
Caliphate has been 100% destroyed and
the founder and leader of Isis the
bloodthirsty killer known as al-baghdadi
is dead back tech we now are learning
about the resurgence and reasserting of
Isis with the number two in command
replacing al-baghdadi exactly as
predicted Isis actually a growing
problem in Iraq and Syria these are just
lies joined this evening by Karl and
Marcia Muller after graduating from
college their beautiful daughter Kayla
became a humanitarian aid worker she
once wrote some people find God in
church
some people find God in nature some
people find God in love I find God and
suffering I've known for some time what
my life's work is using my hands as
tools to relieve suffering in 2013 while
caring for suffering civilians in Syria
kayla was kidnapped tortured and
enslaved by Isis and kept as a prisoner
of al-baghdadi himself after more than
500 horrifying days of captivity al
Baghdady
murdered young beautiful Kayla she was
just 26 years old on the night that US
Special Forces operations ended al
Baghdadi's miserable life the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff General
Mark Billy received a call in the
Situation Room he was told that the
brave men of the elite Special Forces
team that so perfectly carried out the
operation had given their mission a name
Task Force 8:14 it was a reference to a
special day August 14th Kayla's birthday
Carl and Marsha
America's warriors never forgot Kayla
and neither will we thank you I mean you
know these either nobody doubts the
tragic nature of these stories obviously
but the way in which they use to justify
particularly para the policies of this
sick
every day America's men and women in
uniform demonstrate the infinite depth
of love that dwells in the human heart
one of these American heroes was Army
Staff Sergeant Christopher hake on his
second deployment to Iraq in 2008
sergeant hake wrote a letter to his
one-year-old son gage I will be with you
again he wrote to gage I will teach you
to ride your first bike build your first
sand box watch you play sports and see
you have kids also I love you son
take care of your mother I am always
with you daddy on Easter Sunday of 2008
Chris was out on patrol in Baghdad when
his Bradley Fighting Vehicle was hit by
a roadside bomb that night he made the
ultimate sacrifice for our country
sergeant Hague now rests an eternal
glory in Arlington and his wife Kelly is
in the gallery tonight joined by their
son who is now a 13 year old and doing
very very well
- Kelly engage Chris will live in our
hearts forever he is looking down on you
now thank you
Oh
you know of course the idea is to
translate this into people saying I'm
gonna vote for Trump in November and and
you know the details of these stories
thank you for not encouraging those very
much
the terror is responsible for killing
sergeant hake was Kassim soleimani who
provided the deadly roadside bomb that
took Chris's life Salamone was the
Iranian regime's most ruthless butcher a
monster who murder or wounded thousands
of American servicemembers in Iraq as
the world's top terrorists allamani
orchestrated the deaths of countless men
women and children he directed the
December dassault and went on to assault
US forces in Iraq was actively planning
new attacks when we hit him very hard
Pentagon denied that's why last month at
my direction the US military executed a
flawless pretty oh geez well hold on
let's presume that apologies I think we
are back here apologies for that his
third State of the Union address to a
joint session of Congress oh dear nation
this is a speech which outline here we
go we've got the softest stuff
in recent months we have seen proud
Iranians raised their voices against
their oppressive rulers the Iranian
regime must abandon its pursuit of
nuclear weapons stop spreading terror
death and destruction and start working
for the good of its own people because
of our powerful sanctions the Iranian
economy is doing very very poorly we can
help them make a very good and short
time recovery it can all go very quickly
but perhaps they are too proud or too
foolish to ask for that help we are here
let's see which road they choose it is
totally up to them good thing I had a
backup
as we defend American lives we are
working to end America's wars in the
Middle East in Afghanistan the
determination and valor of our war
fighters has allowed us to make
tremendous progress in peace talks are
now underway I am NOT looking to kill
hundreds of thousands of people in
Afghanistan many of them totally
innocent
it is also number from bombs on other
nations as law enforcement agencies
these are war fighters that we have the
best in the world and they either want
to fight to win or not fight at all we
are working to finally end America's
longest war and bring our troops back
home remember he dropped record five
yeah
war places a heavy burden on our
nation's extraordinary military families
especially spouses like amy Williams
from Fort Bragg North Carolina and her
two children six-year-old Ileana and
three-year-old Roe and Amy works
full-time and volunteers countless hours
helping other military families for the
past seven months she has done it all
while her husband sergeant first last
Townsend Williams is in Afghanistan on
his fourth deployment in the Middle East
Amy's kids haven't seen their father's
face in many months Amy your family
sacrifice makes it possible for all of
our families to live in safety and a
peace and we want to thank you thank you
Amy
but Amy there is one more thing tonight
we have a very special surprise I am
thrilled to inform you that your husband
is back from deployment he is here with
us tonight
and this just has no place for the State
of the Union these are this is a reality
show
he sees the reality
why
wow what a great president they form in
November right I mean that the problem
is that this president works on people
Minh even thought thought that soldier
this table okay
[Applause]
welcome home sergeant Williams thank you
very much as the world bears witness
tonight America is a land of heroes
there's a place where greatness is born
where destinies are forged and where
legends come to life this is the home of
Thomas Edison and Teddy Roosevelt of
many great generals including Washington
Pershing Patton and MacArthur Patton
this is the home of Abraham Lincoln
Frederick Douglass
Amelia Earhart Harriet Tubman the Wright
brothers Neil Armstrong and so many more
this is the country where children learn
names like Wyatt Earp Davy Crockett and
Annie Oakley this is the place where
Wingo games landed at Plymouth and where
Texas Patriots made their last stand at
the Alamo
the beautiful beautiful Alamo the
American nation was carved out of the
vast frontier by the toughest strongest
fiercest and most determined men and
women ever to walk on the face of the
earth
our ancestors braved the unknown tamed
the wilderness settled the Wild West
lifted millions from poverty disease and
hunger vanquished tyranny and fascism
assured the world to new heights of
science and medicine laid down the
railroads dug out the canals raised up
the skyscrapers and ladies and gentlemen
our ancestors built the most exceptional
Republic ever to exist in all of human
history and we are making it greater
than ever before don't you fear that
when people die before that I have
do they commit impossible
this is their glorious and magnificent
inheritance we are Americans we are
pioneers we are the Pathfinders we
settle the new world we built the modern
world and we change history forever by
embracing the eternal truth that
everyone is made equal by the hand of
Almighty God he doesn't believe it I
mean this guy's arguably the least
religious president in the modern era
the idea that anyone would believe this
it's easy
America is the place where anything can
happen
America is the place where anyone can
rise and here on this land on this soil
on this continent the most incredible
dreams come true this nation is our
canvas and this country is our
masterpiece we look at tomorrow and see
unlimited frontiers just waiting to be
explored our brightest discoveries are
not yet known our most thrilling stories
are not yet told our grandest journeys
are not yet made he really seems to mean
it the American age the American epic
the American adventure has only just
begun our spirit is still young the Sun
is still rising God's grace is still
shining and my fellow Americans the best
is yet to come
[Applause]
oh the big cut away from Nancy ripping
it up the see about can rip it up it
looked like Nancy was about to rip up
that last page
she is ripping it up yes you've gotta
love it oh my goodness that I cannot
have it and tossing it onto the desk can
you imagine what a brutal brutal take
down below see right behind him ripping
it to shreds wow this is 2020 this is
unbelievable 2020 it is that that is a
Power Move if I have ever seen and
that's a that's a big congratulations
there to a Nancy Pelosi Wow Wow
we have seen just truly truly an
incredible night of pawns and props lies
and deception allusions to a
Christianity that clearly is not really
the Christianity of Donald Trump
unbelievable I mean just this is this is
incredible what an incredible incredible
evening I will we are going to hear from
Bernie Sanders eventually Trump signing
some dudes tie we are oh it was that Jim
Sensenbrenner I'm not sure who that is
we are going to eventually hear the
rebuttal from from from Bernie Sanders
the Democratic rebuttal I will take
questions via super chat I want to say
thank you while the speech was going on
the blue bar filling filling filling
with new members let me just get caught
up and thank amazing people who signed
up and took advantage of my birthday
special while Trump was lying Jacobs
Aveda Justin back Hughes James Garmin I
want to say thanks to Joshua Barker Matt
ox digger ah
Ziggler I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly Andrew gray Jared Morgan Ryan
Mitchell Rosa Leo Tellez Sean p-card
Keith Williams Parker Jacob Hill so many
great people I hope I'm not
not missing anybody Chris Torgerson and
Jason Moskowitz signed up Britney Kramer
welcome Britney James Nicholson Vicente
a dragon a Bradley Ward who else
RJ D'Angelo Rodrigo Aceves and I believe
I'm caught up
jóska ran Sandhu and Carole Mears I
believe that gets me caught up if you've
been just hanging out
I invite you please do take advantage of
the membership special at 60% off you
see the link right up there and it
really does support these streams I
would love it if if if folks did sign up
David he never shook the speaker's hand
says Anthony Sanchez yes that is true
Dutch Morgan says palazzi having a
temper tantrum because Trump didn't
shake her hand
James montalbano says I love hearing him
wheeze I love how unhealthy he sounds I
hate that I love it but this is where we
are now have another Big Mac Trump have
ten Arif Akhtar says the tiny hands of
God
finish ravi says was this boomer porn
seriously Ricky Williams says I was
waiting for sting to drop from the
rafters and stare at palazzi but it
never happened yeah that we we stopped
short of that we stopped short of that
let me say thanks to chill SD for
subscribing on Twitch comfy camper
subscribed on twitch thanks guys I
appreciate it
Alan Byers says America made planes made
with foreign parts from China India
Mexico and more guys I think that we had
bingo I published my bingo card for so
do 2020 this morning let's just go
through and see what we got Trump
attacked socialism Trump claimed we are
building the wall didn't mention perfect
phone call or impeachment or witch-hunt
he slurred his speech he said Gina
he was constantly sniffing he talked
about black unemployment he talked about
Obama indirectly the previous
administration and I guess okay so we
got about half of them I had about half
of them when you look closely it doesn't
look
that good it appears that we still have
no more updates out of Iowa no more
updates out of Iowa and we are any
second going to be seeing the rebuttal
from Bernard Sanders I also liked when
he said statuary city's that was
arguably my favorite moment of the
entire thing sanctuary cities I do see
people mentioning that they tried to
sign up for a membership during the
speech and that the website was down the
website is back up it is fully up and
running and it is running beautifully so
if you were trying to use the coupon
code 36 today and it didn't work
apologies the website was getting
absolutely hammered the banhammer was
coming down on the website by all means
take this opportunity to go ahead and
and grab that membership I believe we
were expecting Bernie baby within 15
minutes or something like that that's
what I that's what I'm being told by
some of my contacts let me say thank you
to hosting Smith hosteen Smith is new
member number 35 today thanks hosteen I
appreciate the support tomorrow on the
show there will be full detailed
analysis of the just atrocities that we
heard tonight 7:00 Jade stars thank you
for subscribing on Twitch I appreciate
that you are subscriber 873 on Twitch 8
7 3 very very much appreciated if you
are heading out and not going to stay
for the Bernie Sanders rebuttal please
make sure to give us a like on Facebook
on your way out would love it also if
you hit that subscribe button those
things are free they really do support
the show and they really do help us in
the YouTube algorithm so I very very
much appreciate those things we will not
be caring the Bernie rebuttal it it's
just been a lot lately so we are going
to be wrapping our coverage I do want to
say thanks to Patrick Standish who is
new member number 36 of the evening but
on that note our coverage ends we will
have a full review of Trump's pee
and the Bernie rebuttal on